maria ciao a tutti benvenuti sanità
styles oggi nuovo episodio trovano
ingredienti slime però ci sarà con un
personaggio ancora più inquietante che
idee chucky la bambola assassina berlino
lo sto già cercando standard in tv a
cercarla praticamente dovrò trovare
tutti gli ingredienti slime è riuscire a
fare lo slime prima che c'è chi mi
prenda per tre volte
quindi se vi prende per tre volte ho
persi invece riesco appare lo slime
prima che mi prendo tre volte ho vinto
la challenge e ciò che scomparirà spero
quindi mettetevi pure comodi
prendete le patatine e il pop corn e
iniziamo subito questa challenge con la
bambola assassina
ok come potete vedere quest'anno al
trust utilizzati da una stanza diversa
che rumore sta facendo per gli otto
berlino berlino che c'è berlino forse
vuole avvisare di qualcosa non viene in
soccorso solo dormendo
comunque sto iniziando da salotto una
stanza diversa ora non ho visto al
sharqi e ora
[Musica]
avvisatemi se vedete qualche di monte
mario ciao mio saluto a tutti è successo
all orecchio
ecco fatto quando sembra che non ci sia
proprio un bel niente
[Musica]
[Applauso]
innanzitutto come ad esplorare la casa
cosa trovi che sia perché devo andare di
qua che c'è lì dentro verdino
[Musica]
no no no no
non fatelo
ma con o no c'è chi mi ha già preso ma
ho trovato la colla sono riuscite a
notarla perché la colla che si illumina
al buio quindi ho visto una cosa
luminosa e l'ho presa al volo nonostante
ciò che mi stesse in seguito
anzi per fortuna sono riuscito a
prenderla e ora non mi resta che trovare
la ciotola la spatola la soluzione per
lenti il bicarbonato di sodio e o solo
altri due possibilità cercherò di non
sprecare le mie altre possibilità
macchina rimasto alla con jobs non posso
andare a prenderlo rischio di perdere le
mie altre opportunità
quindi cerchiamo guai questa stanza se
c'è qualcosa
mi sembra che qua non ci sia proprio
niente
conosciamo meglio nella casetta dobbiamo
tornare a vedere dove sono gli altri
ingredienti tv interno per questo è
l'ingaggio
secondo te mi piace qualcosa qua perché
siamo il 99 dei fiori non so niente nei
fiori dove ci deve portare se facciamo
una bastato grazie per lì mi ha avvisato
che però la ciotola berlino ora vado ad
appoggiarla sul tavolo
abbiamo già delle cose è perfetto e ora
torniamo in quella stanza paura che il
rosé apro la porta spinto
[Musica]
nella casetta
per un po mi ha preso il problema è che
marina del mastro dentro ma non posso
andare a prendere un posto così avanti
mi manca solo il bicarbonato e la botola
vai via tu nascosta dietro è ancora lì è
la borda guardate forse meglio che sto
qua fin piano pavia
non voglio sprecare un'altra possibilità
né assoluto e qui siamo a un punto
perché ho già preso tre cose vi basta
solo trovare il bicarbonato e la spatola
mi dispiace per merlino che è rimasto
con lui
continuare adesso a cercare le cose qua
non c'è niente
non c'è proprio niente qua devo
ricordare bene la porta il tourmalet iva
michelino stata uno dei quattro anni fa
a taranto che cos'era una sorta di
indovinello non mi ricordo anche cosa ha
detto ha detto di ricercare uno di 4
non lo trovi avrei perso
beh in effetti ho solo un'altra
possibilità
non so se riuscirò a farcela ma almeno
so dov'è il bicarbonato lo avete visto
anche voi meriti vanno tira quindi non
so cosa si riferisse ha detto spatola
uno dei quattro vediamo guardiamoci bene
attorno
dobbiamo trovare quattro cose uno dei
quattro dovremmo essere quattro
stiamo pertanto potrebbe essere una di
queste sei perché le sedie sono quattro
ma non ha senso non condividiamo le 6
non c'è niente in queste sedie quindi
non può essere questo che cosa si sono
quattro corpi umani sono 23
[Musica]
[Applauso]
grazie primo impatto su un con simboli
non so perché intanto qualcosa si è
ripromesso pensavo che dovesse risolvere
le novità
prima vediamo ma se ci sono quattro cose
un'alta una qua ci sono 12 cassetti un
altro cassetto
questi sono delle ance sono 1 2 3 4
aspetti al momento queste sono quattro
forse intendeva dire questo è ciò che
devi aprire una delle quattro ante che
forse ci siamo
forse questa è la soluzione
all'indovinello però quale sarà la
numero uno di queste potrebbe essere
questa ma potrebbe essere questa
potrebbe anche tre questa dipende da
dove parte però forse inizia da qui non
beh io provo ad aprire questa se quella
sbagliata
avremmo perso la vita un niente
ecco la foto di volo all trovato anche
la spatola mi manca solo il bicarbonato
e sto benissimo dov'è la dietro certo
non sarà molto facile recuperarlo ma
almeno so dov'è ok
[Musica]
non sarò mai
guardate e li tiene in vita il malato
perché
sono dubbi può prenderlo
io sei sta tentando
certo
difficoltà combattendo
mentre berlino con volte sbrighiamoci
facciamo così i ragazzi richiamo siluro
tempo che è distratta giochi di squadra
con soluzioni per lenti grigio fatto
bicarbonato ne studia sbrigati spiegate
sbagliati strega titoli via t arrivando
poi ci favorirono dentro perché non si
attivi perché
[Applauso]
[Musica]
tutto è ancora delicata
ecco ma è pronto perché non stupidi come
comportarsi gara arrestati che cos'è
questa cosa che lascia così ha lasciato
una bambola devo provare a fare sparire
anche questa colonna slime vediamo non
succede niente perché non succede niente
non capisco già chi è scomparso quindi
vuol dire che abbiamo finito lasciato
questa
bambola c'è scritto c'è chi lo stesso un
pochino si somigliano ma questa bambola
sembra una bombola buona vedete
sorridendo che cosa devo fare
devo aprirla che parla in inglese times
a kimono play utile vuoi giocare che
faccio ragazzi devo per la notte
lasciate un mi piace se volete che apra
questa bambolina nel prossimo episodio
la biro
[Musica]